[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui mercredi
5 avril parole à bruno myle yens
président du modem 78 est désormais
responsable du comité démocrate du
soixante dix huit avec ma tronche fruit
de l'alliance entre le candidat en
marche et françois bayrou nous verrons
avec lui la place de ce comité dans la
campagne du président présidentielle du
favori des sondages
paroles aussi dans cette émission à
christian levrat re porte parole de
l'église mormone en france alors que le
premier temple de l'église de jésus
christ des saints des derniers jours et
bientôt inaugurée au chesnay dans les
yvelines non débutent donc cette
émission avec de la politique bruno
millièmes bonsoir soit vous êtes je le
disais le responsable du comité
démocrate du 78 avec macron aussi
président du modem dans les yvelines
avant de parler de l'actualité locale
un mot sur le débat de mardi soir à 11
premiers débats en france de ce type là
qu'en avez-vous pensé à titre personnel
est-ce que ça a permis de mettre les
choses au clair ou alors c'était assez
brouillon je vais être très honnête et
je vais faire mon mea culpa j'étais
assez sceptique sur le sur la formule à
11 parce que je me suis sa lettre
inintelligible est en fait pas du tout
alors on n'a pas été dans le son on n'a
pas évidemment pas le temps d'aller dans
le fond quand chaque participant en
grosso modo 17 minutes d'intervention
sur les presque 4 heures qu'a duré ce
débat en revanche ça nous a permis de
mieux connaître pour ceux qui ne les
connaissais pas ce qu'on appelle les
petits candidats c'est un petit peu
péjoratif parce que s'ils ont les 500
signatures
ce ne sont pas dans ce classement les
sondages pour dire ça oui c'est une
souvent généralement rentrée oui enfin
bon là la marge avait quand même
importante et ça a permis d'amener moi
je pense un petit peu de fraîcheur et je
me faisais la réflexion en venant que
peut-être même si ces epci launay ce qu
il va y avoir de l'émiettement chez
certains candidats parce que quand on a
vu les performances de certains de
certains comme poutou nathalie arthaud
ça peut grignoter quelques joints
jean luc mélenchon descola dupont aignan
peu de les doter quelquesoit un françois
fillon et personne à ce qu'il voit et
voilà emmanuel macron on va justement en
parler puisque c'est le candidat choisit
désormais par le modem dans les yvelines
vous avez donc lancé ce comité démocrate
du 78 expliquez-nous à quoi va-t-il
servir concrètement ce comité est ce que
vous allez faire campagne commun avec le
mouvement en marche local
alors on est déjà en campagne avec le
mouvement marché cale local on a voulu
créer démocrate 78 avec macron c'est une
idée pour nous de rassembler au delà de
notre propre famille centriste certains
déçus de la primaire notamment de la
droite et de son résultat ça va deux
verres les jus pays ça va bien les déçus
de l'idée que j'invite à venir le
rejoindre en toute liberté ils n'auront
pas eu à voir d'action de désengagement
vis-à-vis de leurs mouvements politiques
mais s'ils se reconnaissent plus dans
l'action et dans le rassemblement que
porte emmanuel macron ils sont les
bienvenus dans ce comics il n'y a pas de
désengagement il ya quand même un signe
important à rejoindre ce comité est ce
qu'ils sont ils sont nombreux les gens
qui qui vous rejoignent et qui sont pas
forcément du modem qui sont de lui des
ihu des républicains carrément ou à
lille demain certains on enlève
renvoyant à des coûts en europe on en a
beaucoup donc après chacun est seul face
à ses bulletins dans l'isoloir chacun
mettra le bulletin qui veut mais il ya
quand même beaucoup d'interrogations
chez les anciens juppéiste et chez les
udi alors localement vous le disiez vous
faites campagne avec le mouvement en
marche d'un point de vue national on
voit finalement assez peu françois
bayrou s'engager réellement dans la
campagne de d'emmanuel macron même s'il
y aura un meeting national à pau le 12
avril selon vous c'est c est un choix
assumé du
une de l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle françois bayrou ou alors
c'est une volonté plutôt des manuels
macron ma réponse je pense que c'est ni
l'un ni l'autre
je pense que c'est ni l'un ni l'autre je
pense qu'ils m'appellent mâcon mène sa
campagne de manière tout à fait
satisfaisante
on va fêter les un an dans marche pas
dessus aujourd'hui ou demain je me
souviens plus donc en marche le
mouvement à un an d'existence
vous voyez quand même le chemin par
cause donc pour assurer ses meetings la
façon de s'exprimer je pense qu'il n'en
avait pas marre on a besoin de personne
en revanche je pense que la peur de
françois bayrou est très important au
niveau de l'expérience d'une campagne
présidentielle et les deux emmanuel
macron et françois bayrou s'il ne se
voit pas tous les jours se parle tous
les jours
est-ce que emmanuel macron c'est
finalement à françois bayrou un peu plus
jeunes un peu plus moderne et finalement
j'ai aussi envie de dire de pousser la
question le raisonnement jusqu'à si
emmanuel mâcon remporte l'élection
présidentielle on est bien dans le si
est ce que ce serait pas la victoire
idéologique de françois bayrou qui
portait un peu plus ou moins le même
programme en 2007
alors vous voyez bien que sur les
valeurs sûres les valeurs qui sont
descendus au travers du point emmanuel
macron sur cette idée que pour réformer
la france il faut la faire de manière il
faut le faire de manière consensuelle
donc en rassemblant aussi bien à droite
qu'à gauche et sur des idées neuves
nouvelle
c'est effectivement un message que
françois bayrou a porté en 2007 et qui a
failli fonctionner pour la petite
histoire et puisque nous serons en
meeting à conflans demain conflans
qu'est la terre de michel rocard lequel
michel rocard en 2007 a failli basculer
en faveur de françois bayrou et ne l'a
pas fait je pense que s'il avait fait
les choses auraient été différentes
évidemment cette alliance avec emmanuel
macron elle et pour nous presque logique
en tout cas c'est la logique voyez
dengue depuis 2012 on a essayé de
travailler des alliances notamment avec
la droite sur des projets on l'a fait
sur des projets on a toujours travaillé
le projet avant les mandats les sièges
ça c'est toujours dense a toujours été
notre politique quand il y avait un
projet qui paraissait rassembleur on y
allait avec
avec nos amis de la droite là
aujourd'hui je dirais que je remarche
enfin sur mes deux jambes voilà une
dernière question très rapidement est ce
que au modem on réfléchit déjà aux
élections législatives d'après puisque
emmanuel macron a dit ce sera uniquement
des candidats étiquetés en marche alors
c'est pas tout à fait raison c'est à
dire
oui ce sera des candidats et hector
marche puisque tous les ai tous les
candidats porteront l'étiquette majorité
présidentielle c'est normal c'est ce qui
se fait dans n'importe quelle élection
quand il ya des alliances dont il ya des
candidats eu des à des législatives qui
sont investis par les républicains si
d'aventuré c'est françois fillon qui
gagne ils auront l'étiquette majorité
présidentielle je vous ferai simplement
remarquer que le modem est le seul parti
qui a offert son partenariat
emmanuel macron alors que son leader
aurait pu se présenter ne s'est pas
présenté toutes les autres formations
politiques quand un leader
donc nous sommes le seul parti à avoir
une alliance avec le manche merci à
bruno emilienne d'être venu en plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes le responsable
nouveau responsable du comité démocrate
du 78 avec macro et de la politique à la
religion on poursuit cette émission avec
vous christian levrat re bonsoir vous
êtes ici en plateau pour parler de
l'inauguration du premier et unique
temple mormon en france il ouvre ses
portes au public le 22 avril après des
mois voire des années très compliqué des
polémiques des recours administratifs ça
doit être un soulagement pour votre
communauté j'imagine l'ouverture de
enfin de ce temple c'est une très grande
joie en effet que de pouvoir finalement
avoir ce temple qui est un lieu très
important pour notre communauté
c'est un lieu de rassemblement c'est une
occasion pour nous de d'accéder à des
ordonnances très importante
partiellement sacré est en général un
temple par pays
donc ça va être vraiment c'est une
grande fête qui va commencer
alors expliquez nous un petit peu en
france il ya il ya des église mormone
déjà qu'ils sont présentes notamment
deux dans les yvelines
mais c'est une première pour un temple
qu'il est là quelle est la différence et
quel est le rôle finalement d'un temple
comparer une église
tout à fait nous avons environ 110
église sur le territoire national les
églises sont des lieux pour le culte
dominical
c'est là aussi que nous avons dans la
semaine des activités récréatives
sociale beaucoup d'activités qui se font
pour la jeunesse dans différents
programmes d'entraidé tu sais que nous
faisons mais le temps pluie à une
fonction particulière c'est d'une
fonction vraiment je dirais spirituelle
pour nous le temps présente une sorte de
trait d'union entre les cieux et la
terre c'est un lieu
on va presque en pèlerinage si je
pourrais dire c'est à dire un lieu de
pour se ressourcer spirituellement un
lieu pour se retrouver pour sortir un
petit peu du monde et se rapprocher du
divin donc c'est aussi un lieu
particulier puisque on peut y faire des
alliances particulière en particulier le
mariage savait que pour nous on se marie
à la mairie bien évidemment mais après
le mariage que nous concevons comme
étant un mariage pour le temps et pour
l'éternité se fait seulement dans les
temples alors dans ce temple est ce que
vous attendez énormément de monde
puisque c'est le seul de france
je crois qu'à peu près un peu moins de
40 milles mormons si je peux me
permettre
en france vous attendez du coût 48
personnes tous les ans qui pourrait
venir aux chaînés non 38 mille membres
de l'église saints des derniers jours
comme les appels de son territoire
français il y en a environ 28 milles
dans les dom-tom d'envoyer 70 milles
environ dans la francophonie
voilà en france on va dire bien
évidemment non en fait le temple va
donner l'occasion membre de venir ce
seront 10 occasions familiales pour les
mariages sont des occasions quand je
faisais de recueillement donc voilà on
compte environ on aura peut-être 150
personnes maximum
surtout le samedi mais dans la journée
dans la journée deux semaines peut-être
80 où une centaine de personnes
devraient avoir des foules en plus qu'un
parking souterrain dont on sera très
discret ce temple dont on a vu quelques
images à l'écran sera donc ouvert à tout
public pendant plusieurs jours du 22
avril au 13 mai prochain est ce que
c'est aussi important de s'ouvrir comme
ça au public et de peut-être tordre le
cou à des idées reçues notamment sur
certains qui disent que vous êtes une
secte par exemple tout à fait mal
grenoble france est tout à fait reconnu
le fait que nous sommes une église
sommes une église chrétienne
une église qui prend des valeurs comme
celles de la famille valeur tout à fait
traditionnelle dans notre pays et c'est
important de pouvoir le fait souffrir
puisque après une fois que ce tome sera
consacrée seuls les membres pour y aller
pour ses sacrements dont je parle est
donc là c'est l'occasion d'y venir c'est
ouvert à tout le monde
voilà c'est vraiment ouvert au public et
on va de pièce en pièce on explique ce
qui se passe dans le temple c'est
vraiment l'occasion de découvrir après
le 13 mai ses portes closes pour le
reste du public voilà en fait ça ne
rouvrira pendant de l'église qui à
partir du 23 mai et là en effet ce sont
pour les membres de l'église comme comme
beaucoup d'édifices sacrés dans le monde
qui sont réservées aux membres de la
communauté
alors on voit encore une nouvelle fois
des images du temple expliquez-nous
comment on commence à se concrétise un
peu à l'intérieur à quoi ça ressemble ce
sont plutôt des petits espaces qui sont
privilégiés je vois là voilà les pièces
les plus grandes ne peuvent contenir
environ une quarantaine de personnes
c'est très beau vers il ya de
magnifiques vitraux les architectes qui
sont toujours en lice dans l'exotique
locaux essayent de donner une dimension
voilà je dirais locale ça coûte cher un
tel temps que j'allais vous poser la
question comment vous financez intel a
fait le temps passa c'est un point
intéressant puisque l'église veut être
autonome finance elle-même
en fait ce sont les dons la dîme en
particulier qui est un des principes de
notre église des manques du monde entier
qui fait du monde entier par aidera
uniquement français n'ont
malheureusement d'une annonce d'autres
pays sur d'autres religions d'autres
communautés
là ça peut être par exemple elle est
très présente elle vient des états unis
d'amérique 7
les mormons vienne deviennent des états
unis d'amérique ça peut venir aussi des
états unis d'amérique
oui bien évidemment ne se peuvent venir
des membres d'amérique du sud doit elle
de bakou c'est vraiment cette idée et
ski raid de communauté de partage ont
construit celui de la france en ce
moment rome et enfin de se faire
lisbonne a commencé voilà et puis
évidemment ce seront d'autres temps pas
qu'il y en a cinq qui ont été annoncés
la semaine dernière
donc ça continue environ 150 tentes dans
le monde entier une dernière question
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas votre
religion peut-on devenir normaux et si
oui comment
bien sûr ils l'ont fait devenir membre
il suffit évidemment de s'intéresser de
voir si les gens ressortent des choses
ici ils se sentent touchés par l'esprit
et s'ils ont le sentiment qu'il ya là un
message qui leur convient on n'est pas
fermés du coup espaces clos
familiale ou à non non absolument pas
non non il ya des centaines de milliers
de membres qui se joignent à l'église
tous les ans donc non c'est tout à fait
ouvert il n'y a pas de problème tout le
monde de venir nous voir
au contraire on invite tout le monde est
donc n'oubliez pas à ces dates à partir
du 22 heures voilà c'est très jusqu'au
13 mai au fil des ans
merci christian revoir d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que le porte
parole de l'église mormone en france
merci aussi plus généralement à vous
deux d'être venu en plateau c'est la fin
de ce set 8 les invités pour ce soir
prochain rendez vous demain d'ici là
retrouvez toutes nos séquences sur notre
site internet tv fil 78 points comme
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
m